speakers charlie mark thank you for
having him here he's a rising senior
college sent me the program I'm a rising
senior at Haverford College and I'm
representing work so about a year ago I
was working with a group of
oceanographers and we had a dataset of
about a hundred thousand images of the
deep-sea and as it currently was we were
humans were trying to annotate these
images for things like biology asking
questions like is there coral in this
image is there two forms and things like
that and this takes a lot of time so
we're asking is can we have computer
vision do this for us and we found was
that on the training set we were able to
do pretty well and within dives of the
autonomous vehicle where we had already
seen images it was able to do pretty
well but in new dives it wasn't able to
transfer those to those new domains very
well so interested in like why were we
seeing this poor domain transfer and we
started to be curious whether our model
was actually learning what we're
interested in or whether it was learning
some lazy proxies such as like on dyes
where there isn't much coral and so just
as this was the water quality this day
and I'm just gonna say if I see that
water quality if there's no coral but we
as domain experts know that that's not
actually some correlation that we can
trust in the population so we're inching
like what information our model is
learning on even if our data is not
directly oh that's not a direct feature
in our data and we quickly realized that
this is a similar problem that we're
trying to answer off to in fairness
right so we're trying to audit the
scenario of when there's proxies for
things that were interested in
essentially for example except code as a
proxy for race and we're trying to
understand like what is driving this
decision in this notion of indirect
influence so in a case like red lining
we're curious like is something like
race indirectly influencing my decisions
and how I might start to understand
whether or not that's happening
so in general there's a couple ways
right so I guess like our general
question is what we're trying to figure
out is we have a model and we have an
example in which is making a prediction
and we're trying to understand how is it
doing this okay there are a couple of
ways we can think about this question
the first natural way to think about it
is what we're going to call direct
influence so we're going to say is the
future P used when I'm making my
prediction right so in this example I
have a decision tree right and if I ever
come across a node where I go a
different direction based on my value of
P and I would make a different
prediction depending on which way I went
I'd say maybe I think P is having a
direct influence right it's changing my
prediction and so for example like in a
certain tree we can think about is it
hitting a node and I know network we
might think about gradients and there's
other methods in different contexts
where we can think about what direct
influence might mean the other notion
might be interested in is indirect
influence so in this notion we're asking
is the feature P used by the model or
additionally is a proxy for the future P
used by the model so in this dish isn't
rewrite the feature P doesn't appear but
there's a feature x2 so instead of
asking if P is greater than one we're
asking if x2 is greater than two but in
general x2 is about equal to two P so
this is in some sense a similar decision
tree right and like it's using similar
information and information from P might
still be determing decisions even though
P isn't directly being used okay so this
is the kind of the kind of question
we're interested in seeing if we can
tackle so what our goal is for each
instance in our data set we'd like to
quantify the indirect influence of each
feature on the prediction of a model so
that might look like is like for
something like here right we have an
instance which is like feature one is
causing it to be slightly greater than
otherwise would have feature two is
doing you know slightly less then we'd
like you'll do this for each instance
then across the dataset we can see you
know on you know in general however
feature is being treated in addition to
like on specific instances what's kind
of happening behind the scenes of this
indirect influence so interesting is
there discrimination what are the
pathways that result in that like what
are the proxy variables and what kind of
examples specifically in the days that
are subject to discrimination so with
within a group right some individuals
might be bearing more of the burden
discrimination than other individuals
okay so this can be a computationally
difficult problem right because it
involves understanding the relationships
between different variables so if we're
trying to understand if something's
being influenced or a decision is being
influenced to be a proxy we first have
to understand what other proxies and all
of these higher-order relationships
which can be difficult so we'd like to
do is reduce this difficult indirect
influence problem to a simpler in some
cases direct influence problem because
there's other people who've done great
work in that area
so if we can kind of leverage their work
and translate our problem to their
problem our problem gets easier so some
of this great work here we're interested
in saying like critics can we turn our
problem into their problem okay so the
general thing we're gonna try to do is
we're going to take this original
problem where we have a protected
feature P and a bunch of other features
X and we're trying to look at the
indirect influence on some model which
is making a prediction Y hat and we're
gonna say can I can I swap my features
out for a new set of features P and X
Prime where the features X Prime
are similar to X except X prime is
independent of P right so there's
there's no relationship between P and X
Prime and because of that we're going to
change our model to M prime so that it
will make the same predictions on px
prime as M would have made on px and now
instead of getting Y we're gonna Y hat
we're gonna get Y hat prime which we're
going to hope is gonna be like about the
same prediction because we want this to
be at the same model and we're gonna
argue that direct influence on this
model is the same as the original
indirect influence
okay so the kind of main driving
methodology behind what we're gonna do
rests on disentangled representations so
Rick's mo mentioned this a little bit
yesterday and what doesn't take the
representation is trying to do is they
look at recovering independent packages
of variation from dependent features
right so we say that in the world behind
our data there's these independent knobs
right that changed the world state and I
can turn one of them and it will change
the features I get and I don't have to
change the other now is behind the
scenes right so there's kind of
independent settings in the world and
they're going to give rise to our
dependent features right so talk about
this we're gonna walk through an example
and then formalize it a little bit so in
our simplest example world we're gonna
say we have a five by five grid and this
is the world and on our good we have a
ball which can take any of four colors
and the different world states are the
different positions and colors of the
ball so one world state might be right
here where it's at like the position
three one and it takes the color red
right okay so we say if we say that X Y
and C vary independently right we can
say we have these independent factors of
variation X Y and C and from them we
make some observations because we have
some sensors of this world right but we
see as soon as you've made these
observations we lose this independence
so our features are very dependent right
so now we're gonna try to do is we're
gonna generate a disentangled
representation which can recover from
this representation some new
representation which observes the
independence of the independent factors
of variation okay so kind of formalize
that setting we're gonna say the set of
world states is a set W which we're
gonna compose as a Cartesian product and
we have a group of world state
transitions which we're going to compose
as a direct product of subgroups and
we're going to say that the group G acts
on the set W somebody Boop action says
is pretty much an element of the group G
when you act on the set W it'll just mix
up the elements it just permutes them
right and we're gonna say that this
group action is disentangled if the two
subgroups of G each fix the component of
W that doesn't correspond to them so say
that G one only acted on Tripoli on w1
and likewise for G 2 and W two
right so we can kind of think about this
like world state transitions simply the
way that g1 accent W 1 and G 2 X on W 2
right so as an example here we could say
like let's say I had the the action
right of moving to the left 2 and
changing colors I'd say okay I'm gonna
move from here to here to here and go to
green right and I can think about that
as independent of any Y movement right I
can just think about that hopping
independently so all I have to think
about is how am i changing the x
coordinate of this point I don't have to
think at all about what's happening the
y coordinate right because they're
disentangled okay but the difficulty is
and in the real world we don't have
access to these independent world states
so we have is these these muddled
features right so we'd like to do is say
can we take these observations and
recover this independence right so we
say that disentangled representation
which is a function all the way from the
world sits these encodings which has to
pass through the observations first
we'll encode the world States into some
independence structure right and
formally what we're saying when you say
that is that a disentangled represents a
disentangled representation if the group
action on Z so first it was actor and W
we're saying we're gonna see can we find
a new group action on Z such that it's
also observes the same disentanglement
so Z will decompose similarly as W did
right and similarly G one only acts on Z
1 and likewise for G 2 and Z 2 and we
also you this equivariance which is that
kind of a consistency property which I'm
happy to go into more depth if anyone's
interested but pretty much what it says
is that like f and action by G need to
commute so it kind of like gives us a
world state dynamic on these encoded
this encoded set Z ok so that last
section was pretty much the theory of
arena Higgens and a couple other folks
and so kind of we're gonna bundle that
up and say can we use their work and
extend that to figure out this problem
of indirect influence so what they're
saying is we think we can you know
formalize this a notion that
disentangled representations recover
independent factors variations from
dependent features and the way we're
going to try to extend that is to define
indirect influence of the feature p on
the model m at the instance PX as
instead in world state so we're saying
okay well these features are functions
these worlds
so now we're gonna say W 1 and W 2 are
gonna be WP and WX which correspond to
the protected and unprotected world
states and we're going to say that B
observes these world States and will
give us features ok so we're saying
we're you said in direct influence is
actually happening in these world states
and furthermore these world states WP
and WX
we're going to define the world the
protected world state to be the
protected information we have so we're
saying the information we want to
understand how it's being affected or
how it's affecting our prediction is the
information exactly the information
that's encompassed in the future P ok
and that information might also be
affecting the rest of the features X
right but we're saying that there's no
relationship between W X and P ok so
when we talk about indirect influence on
M of this function of W P we can then
say pretty much you can pull that into a
composed function and say we're actually
going to be auditing the function which
is now a function of world States and it
first observes and then makes a
prediction and here w p + WX are by
construction independent so there can be
no proxies right they are independent so
there's no gonna be know entered like
strictly indirect influence because
there are no proxies so here indirect
influence just reduces to direct
influence the only proxy for a feature
is going to be itself right and this is
something that we can try to compute so
if we can find this correct model which
composes and this like observation
function B then we can just compute the
direct influence on that model okay so
let's start with the basic supervised
learning scenario we have a bunch of
features and we're gonna have a model
and it's just going to make some
prediction right but we're gonna say
okay well in the background I have these
this disentangled representation from
which my features are generated right so
somewhere up in the clouds there's these
independent factors of variation and
that's where my features are actually
coming from so have these like these two
processes right and I'm just gonna
combine them right I'm gonna say okay I
have one process which is going to
generate my features and one which is
going to make a prediction and I'm just
gonna consider those one process right
so I'm gonna say I start with in a pinch
the back independent factors of
variation I'm gonna do some stuff and
then I mean I had a prediction right so
when I combine them I can just say ok I
now have a model of independent type of
independent features
and if I can select one of them to be my
protected information right I can just
let everything else just be the jumbled
mess of other information that don't
need to be interpreted I really care
about at all I can just say it needs to
be everything that is not related to my
protected information now I have a model
where I just would look I can just look
at the direct influence on my future P
okay so learning how to do this is gonna
take a little bit of work we're gonna do
it through an autoencoder
which pretty much tries to learn an
identity function so when Adam Carter
does is right you give it a vector X and
its goal is to just reproduce that
vector X but it has the task that it has
to pass to an information bottleneck so
as to take a large representation pass
it through a small representation and
get back right so it's trying to dense
think oh that information but we're also
gonna say and you're auto-encoder I'm
gonna try to take your latent
representation X Prime at your
information bottle and I can see if I
can find the predicted protected
information from that and if I can
they're not independent right because
I've been able to reveal a way to
predict P from X Prime so I'm gonna
trade this adversary I'm gonna say I
don't want you to be able to predict P
from my Layton representation but when I
give this decoder right the second part
of my autoencoder direct access to P and
X prime then it should have all
information needs to get back right so
I'm trying to just like separate the
protected information from the
unprotected information and then I'm
gonna pass that through the model but
now what I have is my original features
but as a function of a disentangled
representation right so if I just
composed the decoder in the original
model I can just calculate using you
know your favorite feature influence
algorithm what is the direct influence
on that model and we're saying that now
we can actually look at what is the
indirect influence of P on the original
model M okay so I'm gonna move into some
experimental results now you're gonna
see this type of plot a couple times the
way to read this plot is the x-axis is
going to be the score of influence and
so a point far to the right means that
on that point that feature led to a
result with a higher prediction a point
that's like far to the left out here
says that that feature taking that value
led to the prediction being a lot lower
and if it's red it means that that
feature took a high value there and if
it's blue it means that feature took a
low value there so in general features
with high and
we'll see a lot of spread until have a
lot of weight away from the center and
features with low importance will just
kind of be stuck at the middle doing
nothing okay so the first expert we did
is we pretty much randomly generated
from the uniform distribution just three
latent factors X Y and C independently
and then we just generated a future
vector from those deterministically
right so we just pretty much through + 2
y + 2 X and we had a label x + y and we
just handcrafted a model that just grabs
the feature X so my vector grabs feature
Y and adds them right so direct
influence right so we just used an
implementation called shop and it
correctly says what your model is doing
is it's just using the features x and y
nothing else matters if you were to
change those features nothing would
happen right but in the end direct
influence sense we're saying well 2x and
2y matter right because 2x fully reveals
X which is that like put your models
using first decision so in the indirect
influence sense 2x is very important
right so the first thing we do is we
give our method a perfect disentangled
representation because I said we know
how we generated this data this is the
relationship structure and then can you
tell me the indirect influence and we
see kind of similarly to to this simple
example over here it's able to like
correctly say like yeah these six
features now all have the same influence
because they perfectly reveal each other
and the features related to C still
don't matter right but in the real world
we don't actually have any access to
this like disentangled representation
right this what do you do the other
features you keep them think so you
randomly choose settings so we're not
perturbing points at all so we're saying
like there are points in the data set
for which X takes a low value right and
we're just gonna say okay 1 8 6 a low
value so this is just like the
distribution of all points of the data
set kind of looking at their x value
right so we're not doing any sort of
perturbation right we're just saying
like the points with that are blue are
just they just happen to have low X
values
yeah pretty much yeah okay yeah so when
we don't have direct access to this this
disentangle representation we have to
learn it right so we see that like when
we have to start learning these
representations we still get the same
general idea like it's approximating
this but like a little bit of noise
creeps in because it starts like oh is C
model just C matter a little bit in this
scenario I'm not sure so one shouldn't
like understanding next like when should
we trust this audit and when should we
be a little concerned that like maybe
we're going to catch a case where like
this point isn't being quite predicted
correctly being audited correctly so the
first thing we're gonna look at we're
adding this is the reconstruction error
right because instead of passing X into
the model we're actually passing X hat
into the model so if X hat isn't equal
to X we're actually not auditing on
quite the correct point so we can see
like okay when it's all you bottom you
can start perfectly that's a case when
we should be a little concerned so we
can say for each point what was the
reconstruction error the next thing we
look at is the prediction error because
not all mistakes are made alike right
they're gonna be certain prop mistakes
that in reconstruction that our model is
not gonna be very sensitive to like
information that our model is ignoring
if we aren't able to reproduce it
correctly that actually doesn't really
matter that much but you could imagine
there's a small error we make that our
models incredibly sensitive to right and
in that case we could say oh every
construction airs not that bad or odd it
should be good but our model is super
sensitive to it so actually it was a big
problem right so like one kind of like
rough way to look at that is just say
like okay if I actually use my model to
predict on these two values how much
does that differ
unless interested in is like did I
actually successfully disentangle my
representation right so we kind of look
at this this notion of like how much of
the the variance of P was the
discriminate of the adversary able to
recover okay so this is pretty much a
guessing like or getting at the idea of
like are the latent factors independent
and we'd like this these all to be about
equal to one we're just saying that like
all of it was obscured
okay so one nice notion about this
definition in this work is that we can
audit features that aren't actually in
the data set right so in this scenario
we have a bunch of simple simple
synthetic images so they're just purged
generated from five latent features
deterministically and we train a model
that's just trying to like predict
whether or not the shape is a heart and
all it gets access to is the pictures of
this image right so it's just like given
this picture of a square that says is it
a heart and we're interested in is like
well how much does the orientation of
the shape affect that right which is not
something that we can directly audit
because our model is not a function of
that latent factor it's just a function
of these pixels so we're gonna try to
learn is we're gonna remodel can you
understand how the orientation of this
light this latent factor relates to
these pixels so then we can kind of
through those proxies understand how it
is affecting these models predictions
all right
so we see that in this sense it's able
to to correctly note that like shape
seems to be having slightly more
importance than these other features
more time to predict shape just just to
understanding the relationship of these
latent factors to the pixels I apologize
if you if you said this earlier when you
say shape scale orientation are these
things that are these meetings that
we've imposed on the safe five features
in the narrow section of the
auto-encoder or are these things that
we've curated on the examples yeah so
these are labels that were determined
like it's how the image was generated so
it's like we have a data set and for
each data set like so it for each
instance in the data set it has a shape
scale orientation x position in Y
position and using that information it
just like makes the photo okay so it's
not that we have to look at the other
we're not trying to like learn exactly
that thing so we're she was just saying
like can you understand you pull out
shape from everything else you don't
have to like pull out shape and then
scale on the orientation all
simultaneously we're gonna one at a time
pretty much say like what is like the
information of shape and then what is
everything else I'm like just that like
- there's just two elements understand
the code representation and I'm gonna
throw that out start over
say what is the scale what does
everything else
there's anticipation that's a question
okay so then we did some work with the
adult income dataset and we see that
when we audit direct influence it seems
like marital status over here has some
importance but we see that like the
label of being a husband and your sex
isn't that important but then we move
over to indirect influence alright it
says that like well maybe these are more
important features so in this way we
hope that like our model can like raise
red flags so if you have a model and
your word that like you don't want it to
be making decisions based on the sense
of attributes I can just like you know
point you to things that might be being
used as proxy they're being accessed
through proxies so two variables on each
of them I will not see any effect but
these two drivers together very
influential right so you tell me like
intersectional thing isn't like that and
like higher order yeah right so we
actually we've thought a little bit
about how we could extend it this work
to that and if you'd be interested in
talking offline we do have actually some
thoughts that's kind of one of our kind
of look kind like right up front future
directions but indirect influence can
capture some notions of higher order
relationships and the sense that like as
currently pi was gonna say like right
like it still matters right like the
feet in that conjunction like the value
of each individual thing still does
matter right yeah so yeah I definitely
be happy to talk more that I find I'm
because we thought a little bit about
that and actually rich some out works a
little bit also and I kind of like
disentangling multiple things at once
but another question reading the very
tiny print on this screen I can see that
the rectum flutes of Education was large
but the in directs the indirect
influence seems to be zeros yeah exactly
yeah so we noticed that too so that was
something that concerned us as well and
so if you look here so we recurse know
that as well and we noticed that it's
possible actually that is an error right
so we like go to a reconstruction I
Reese's like we have a higher
reconstruction error on education news
so like maybe that is a problem and
furthermore we're not always like trying
to use this as a you know as like the
the flag to post and say like there is a
problem with this model right we're
trying to use it as maybe like a way to
you know give people questions ask one
like and say like I wonder if this is a
problem so there are gonna be cases like
where like it is possible that maybe we
want this this to be bigger right so
we're gonna try to catch that in our
error metrics yeah it's a question so
for each of these different features
you're training a different auto encoder
that individually disentangle is this
particular feature each time yeah yeah
so we're not we're not retraining the
original model but yeah we're like
training a new oven we're training a new
disentangled representation so it's
possible that you can find two highly
quart loop or it's likely that if there
are two highly correlated attributes
then you will say that like both of them
are but then have have a lot of
influence even though they go through
exactly exactly and that's the exact
like thing we want to do right that's
like the property we want from indirect
influence right because like if you
imagine that it features like we're done
that lis in a data set like you have the
feature X and the future X again like a
model may just choose to use one of them
right and then you say that feature is
really important in the other features
not important
but like indirect influence says they're
equally important right because they're
the same feature
so in conclusion we can generate
indirect influence scores on flexible
data types and for individual instances
not just across groups and then from
that we can look at the population we
can do it for features that aren't
directly in the data but that we can
measure and then we can look at
individualized error analysis to try to
catch things and we're like unsure about
certain results if we can like figure
out like when or not when we should or
should not trust them and then select
kind of building on that also one of the
limitations that is the audit can only
be as good as the disentangled
representation is and right now the
disentangled representations work is
it's quite brittle right like these
things often don't work perfectly so
when there's errors and that we're gonna
misunderstand our proxy relationships
and that's gonna be a problem one thing
that we're excited about is like as this
this field develops our method is quite
modular we can get us plug in new
methods for disentangled representations
to generate our just entangled
representation for our method so as that
field develops hopefully our our method
will improve with it and it's best for
auditing local effects it gets more and
more difficult to understand how
changing features works when you get
really far away so it's kind of best it
kind of like local influence as opposed
to like what happened if this this
instance became very different I'll say
thank you and here is the paper and a
link to the code all right thank you
very much we've got plenty of time for
questions
take
I mean have you tried this on any
criminal justice to know someone thing
we're interested in is kind of expanding
the experimental section so we're also
interested in seeing if we can work with
some like facial datasets and things
like that like the celeb a dataset is
used a lot in related literature and
then datasets like that as well
there's a lot of theoretical work on a
scene usually the topic which is
influence of boolean variables on wave
functions right you should see if it
connects at all I haven't looked at
there should very much but it'd be like
really interested to hear and here you
have to say about that if you look a few
words the sensitivity of a function
boolean boolean functions yeah I
definitely love to hear you
all right we can continue all these
discussions about
[Applause]